yeah allergy season is here so if I look
like [ __ ] or sound like [ __ ] or
generally speaking my vibe is [ __ ]
apologies but that's just because this
movie doesn't look that guy so we have
any trailer for Shane blacks the
predator this trailer is better than the
last trailer I bet a full one allergy
attack right this is funny because I put
that on Instagram some people I love the
fact they were like take medicine I was
like no [ __ ] I hadn't thought of it I
get people to try to be helpful but is
it I know what he's in the predator in
terms of information we don't know
anything we didn't already know it looks
like it's gonna be a predator versus
Rangers which is what predator is
supposed to be believe me get the Barry
Bonds of predators predators steroids
which is just something I just don't
need that I've never seen a predator
movie where super predator made for a
better predator movie AVP Requiem had a
super predator Predators had super
predators it was actually pretty
enjoyable one from what I remember what
is you don't always have to make a super
souped-up version of the old thing
people don't say I want another predator
moving I want it to be good thinking to
themselves I want to see super predators
what they want to see is the old
predator which this has but then it's
super predator also take him Michael key
bring him back the mob jokes if your
mom's vagina were a video game would be
rated E for Everyone
that is pretty good guy my [ __ ] voice
is so raspy is what I sound like now
don't smoke kids let's talk about their
predators Phelps yes so there's a big
two-step ready to fight the little
predators and then the Rangers are gonna
come into it what's the over-under that
the old predators gonna team up with the
Rangers for the survival of both species
while they take on super to stop
predators I'll take it 78 percent 150
percent that's actually what happens
that one dude seems to have a lot of
information now that one dude who says
something like predators don't sit
around making hats out of rib cages they
conquered space that's a lot of
information he has I want to know where
he got that like how did he know that
they conquered space and what do you
mean space you mean like spaces in our
galaxies like did they conquer the known
universe does that one mean there is an
empire of predators out there comprised
of all planets but our own and we're
just like what the last stronghold we
just didn't know it there's a super
government surrounding us did they just
find a predator drone who had a map and
that map showed the reach of the
predator Empire [ __ ] my eyes look like
[ __ ] too maybe if I do this hey I look a
little more alive
look like a genuine human being all
right I'm gonna talk like this now how
they do a couple tricks to get you into
it they have the 20th Century Fox logo
and it has the infrared I was like
that's pretty cool at the end they have
the sounds but in terms of being
interested this movie looks too much
like AVP requiem for me to actually give
a [ __ ] or look forward to it I can't do
it I'm sorry I want nothing more than to
be hyped for this new predator movie I
just cannot do it based on the trailers
it looks like the basic Hollywood Way if
we want to recapture the old film for
the nostalgia and bring it into a new
generation but with a super-powered
version of the B's who knows maybe the
movies gonna be awesome this move you
might kill it in all the right ways I
always bring up Ironman one way to talk
about a movie I saw the trailer I
thought it was gonna be acid washed
those like that was actually quite
amazing the predator might be Iron Man
for predator when I heard about this
movie I was like I need to see a trailer
now that I've seen - I couldn't give a
[ __ ] who knows maybe it's the allergies
maybe it's the fact that I took six
times the recommended dosage of allergy
medicine maybe that's maybe like yeah
[ __ ] it all I'm saying for this movies I
will see all right so trailer 2 for the
predator have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know I'll take this
off and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here - I'm out of here
[Music]